oh well oh there I'm gab oh hello I'm
Dan oh hello with the slow mo guys we're
sat down take a seat yourself if you
want no need to stand what won't have
you stood there all right as soon as it
our stomach goes video just this few
months ago we are very kindly given this
car by Traxxas it goes a hundred miles
an hour beast
we used it because it's it was the
fastest car I could find on the Internet
and we had a problem when we were
filming it in that the audio was too
good
crystal-clear sort of so good that it
hurt your ears listen too often the case
on the slo-mo goes on the case here's an
example of it see what I mean yeah very
clear sounds very clear so we're gonna
do is make a new intro for you that is
worse sounding first thing we thought we
do is test out the speed by driving it
at myself yeah a hundred miles an hour i
I thought wouldn't it be cool if you
could jump over a 100 mile an hour
object coming straight at your own legs
I was like yeah so I have to wait I have
to drive it at myself and jump and then
you like also do a 180 so I turn in the
air still controlling the car a hundred
miles now
that's that's scary
[Music]
[Music]
next we decided what would a crash look
like little off-road spill so Dan drove
the car from the flat tarmac onto the
grass and I tracked it in high-speed
this is what it looked like
[Music]
[Music]
serious James Bond flips they're all
kicked up the grass flying for the air
I've done it in real life and let me
tell you it's better to watch it when
it's a remote-control car not you in the
car fiddling with the radio I know yeah
I told people there was an animal and I
swerved to avoid it I was literally just
playing with the radio not paying
attention life span it backwards into a
bush world are there yep
good work next up we thought it'd be a
good idea to pour a lump of flour on the
road and have it drive either over it or
through it either way the particles of
flour should look cool okay so to help
show the speed of this car I'm gonna
plump down an entire bag of flour here
and watch it get obliterated in slow-mo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we were actually mainly out there
filming the flamethrower video of which
all of the audio is fine
somehow the wind must have kicked up
while we're doing this one so you suit
it up again yeah and we drove the car
through the flames
[Music]
[Music]
so at this point we haven't broken this
thing yet somehow so I felt like the
finale was clear just get another one
get a second one of these bad boys this
one's all see-through obviously so we
can see the individual bits when it
crashes into this one we went for a
head-on collision
[Music]
Oh
that wheel is wedged up there yeah it's
like shoved up inside so when we're
filming that I thought a little bit
wasteful we did they're sort of very
high-performance remote-control cars
definitely for enthusiasts yeah but I've
got to say whenever I see a
remote-control car
I always think what would it look like
if two slammed into each other I mean I
know that people that want one of these
cars and use these cars yeah would be
like I really want to crash one with it
but I just can't do it it's mine it's
more of a kit I really want to crash one
I don't want to crash my yeah yeah we've
done it for you in slow motion yeah so
it is wasteful but now you don't have to
experiment and damage your own goods if
you were thinking of it well we won't
worth it I'm not I'm always fascinated
by destruction a big wet thanks to
Traxxas for giving us two free cars and
then repairing them for us they put into
the GTA garage yes very much appreciate
it for the use of this video and uh
hopefully you got some enjoyment out of
it too
feel free to follow us on twitter by
some Smerch and a second channel so
there's a second channel too yeah